I think
the war on terror construct won't seem
that important.
Um,
and I,
I,
uh,
when nine slash 11 happened,
we all believed including me,
that it would be a,
first of all that it was a typical event
like Pearl Harbor,
which now,
you know,
doesn't seem to be the case.
Uh,
and second of all that there would be
many more nine slash 11 or several more,
nine slash 11 and there haven't been.
And I hope there aren't basically,
um,
it,
it may be a with hindsight,
which is always unfair that people will
say,
even though it was by far the worst
terrorist attack in American history,
you have to explain to your
grandchildren why there was such an
extreme reaction to one terrorist attack
and why that,
you know,
seem to quote unquote change everything
about American life and America's role
in the world.
I suspect that that's what we'll think a
generation from now.
And then the other thing I think is,
um,
uh,
I,
I suspect that this may be more of a
hope,
but I,
I think I'm right that,
you know,
when we're sitting around with her
grandchildren,
the level of mistrust or the public
sector will seem nutty in how high it
was during this era.